rubrique santé maintenant attention aux
coupes faim la législation française se
fait plus sévère désormais ces
médicaments devront pour la première
fois être délivrés par des médecins
spécialisés dans les hôpitaux on s'en
était en s'est en effet aperçu que la
vente plus ou moins libre de ses
produits pouvaient avoir de très graves
conséquences caroline glorion puis des
budgets cela maigrir perdre du poids
c'est le combat de françoise depuis des
années
comme des millions d'autres elle a tout
essayé régime pure et même les
médicaments coupe-faim
c'est facile d'obtenir un résultat
quelques heures avec des coupes faim
vous allez devenir la personne vers une
église oui j'étais très énervé
palpitations reebok j'avais peut-être
basculé dans leur des prix car les
couples sont des produits dangereux
ils agissent sur le cerveau et bloquent
la sensation de faim une étude récente a
prouvé aussi qu'il pouvait être
responsable dans des cas très rares de
maladies cardio pulmonaires graves et
mortels l' agence du médicament a donc
décidé aujourd'hui que pour en
bénéficier la première fois il faudra se
rendre à l'hôpital dans un service
spécialisé mais coupe faim qui agissent
au niveau du cerveau sont à réserver aux
personnes qui ont un surpoids important
et surtout chez qu'ils aient surpoids va
être dangereux pour la santé
par exemple les personnes qui ont des
problèmes d'hypertension graves des
problèmes cardiaques des problèmes
articulaires important et qui n'arrive
pas en fait avec un simple régime
associé souvent à la psychothérapie ou à
l'activité physique qui n'arrivent pas à
suffisamment maigrir pour améliorer leur
santé
c'est la première fois qu'une telle
décision est prise en france cette fois
un médicament traditionnellement
prescrit en ville ne pourra l'être qu'à
l'hôpital
la preuve des excès des risques
inconsidérés pris par des acharnés des
régimes amaigrissants rapide efficace
mais illusoire